Dispone de unos 400 kilómetros de autonomía.
CA: El paquete de baterías es muy pesado.
¿Crees que todavía pueden salir las cuentas
si combinamos una carrocería ligera con unas baterías pesadas?
¿Todavía se puede obtener una eficiencia espectacular?
EM: Exacto. El resto del coche tiene que ser muy ligero
para compensar la masa del paquete de baterías.
También hay que conseguir un coeficiente aerodinámico bajo para tener buena autonomía en la carretera.
De hecho, muchos usuarios del Tesla Modelo S
están como compitiendo entre ellos
para alcanzar la mayor autonomía posible.
Creo que alguien obtuvo hace poco unos 670 kilómetros con una sola carga.
CA: Bruno Bowden, que está aquí, lo hizo.
Batió el récord mundial. EM: ¡Felicidades!
CA: Esa es la buena noticia. La mala noticia es que,
para hacerlo, tuvo que andar a 30 kilómetros por hora
hasta que lo paró la policía. (Risas)
EM: Claro, realmente puedes conducir...
si vas a 100 kilómetros por hora,
en circunstancias normales,
400 kilómetros es una cifra razonable.
CA: Vamos a ver el segundo video
que nos muestra al Tesla en acción sobre hielo.
Por cierto, no es para nada, una indirecta al New York Times.
¿Qué es lo más sorprendente
al conducir el coche?
EM: Al crear un coche eléctrico,
la respuesta del coche es simplemente increíble.
Queríamos que la gente se sintiera como si
casi se hubieran fundido con el coche,
como si persona y coche fueran uno,
y si tomas una curva y aceleras, es instantáneo,
el coche tiene ESP.
Con un coche eléctrico esto es posible debido a su gran respuesta.
No es posible con un coche de gasolina.
Creo que esa es la gran diferencia,
y la gente solo puede experimentarla al probar el coche.
CA: En realidad se trata de un coche precioso y muy caro.
¿Tienes un plan para que este vehículo llegue a ser
un producto de masas?
EM: Así es. La meta de Tesla siempre ha sido
tener una especie de proceso de tres pasos,
el primer producto sería un coche caro de bajo volumen de ventas,
el segundo producto es un coche con precio y volumen promedio
y el tercero sería un coche de precio bajo y gran volumen de ventas.
Estamos en el paso dos en este momento.
Es decir, tenemos un deportivo de 100.000 dólares, el Tesla Roadster.
Después está el Tesla Modelo S, que parte de unos $50.000.
Y por último nuestro coche de tercera generación que
debe salir en unos 3 ó 4 años
con un precio de unos $30.000.
En realidad siempre que creas tecnología nueva,
se necesitan unas tres versiones
para lograr un producto atractivo para consumo masivo.
Yo creo que estamos progresando en esa dirección
y tengo confianza en que alcanzaremos la meta.
CA: Es decir, ahora mismo, si la distancia al trabajo es corta,
puedes ir y volver en el coche y recargarlo en casa.
Actualmente no existe una gran red nacional de estaciones de recarga que sean rápidas.
¿Crees de verdad que eso llegará
o en realidad solo habrá en unas pocas rutas importantes?
EM: En realidad hay más estaciones de recarga
de lo que la gente cree.
En Tesla estamos desarrollando
lo que llamamos tecnología de supercargadores
y se la estamos ofreciendo a los compradores del Modelo S
de manera gratuita y para siempre.
Esto es algo que, tal vez, mucha gente desconoce.
En la actualidad tenemos cubiertas California y Nevada,
así como la costa este de los EEUU,
desde Boston a Washington D.C.
Para final de año, se podrá conducir
desde Los Angeles a Nueva York
usando la red de supercargadores,
que recarga cinco veces más rápido que las demás alternativas.
La clave está en tener una proporción de conducción-parada
de uno a seis o siete.
Es decir, si conduces durante tres horas,
haces una parada de unos 20 ó 30 minutos,
porque es lo que la gente haría normalmente.
Si el viaje empieza a las 9 a.m.,
al mediodía lo normal es hacer una parada para comer algo
ir al baño, tomar un café y seguir la marcha.
CA: Tu propuesta es entonces una hora para una recarga completa.
Es normal... no se puede esperar estar en marcha tras 10 minutos.
Hay que esperar una hora, pero lo bueno es que
estás ayudando a salvar el planeta
y, además, la electricidad es gratis. No hay que pagar nada.
EM: En realidad, lo que queremos es que la gente
pare unos 20 o 30 minutos, no una hora.
En realidad es mejor conducir unos 250 kilómetros,
parar media hora
y continuar el viaje.
Es la cadencia natural de un viaje.
CA: Perfecto. Y esto es solo una carta de tu baraja energética.
Estás también trabajando en la compañía de energía solar SolarCity.
¿Qué tiene de especial?
EM: Bien, como he mencionado antes,
tenemos que tener una producción sostenible de energía,
así como el consumo,
pues estoy bien convencido de que los medios principales
de generación de energía serán solares.
Es decir, realmente se trata de fusión indirecta, sí.
Tenemos ese reactor de fusión natural en el cielo que es el Sol.
Solo tenemos que atrapar un poco de esa energía
para servirnos de ella.
Hay algo que mucha gente sabe aun sin pensarlo
y es que el mundo ya funciona casi completamente con energía solar.
Sin el Sol, el mundo sería una esfera helada
a 3 grados Kelvin.
Del Sol también dependen las lluvias.
Todo el ecosistema depende del Sol.
CA: Pero en un litro de gasolina tenemos,
de hecho, miles de años de energía solar
concentrados en algo bien compacto,
por lo que es difícil que salgan las cuentas ahora con energía solar.
Para poder competir, por ejemplo, con gas natural,
¿Cómo planteas tu negocio respecto a esto?
EM: En realidad estoy convencido de que la energía solar
superará a todo y, sin duda, también al gas natural.
(Aplausos) CA: ¿Y cómo?
EM: Bueno, tiene que ser así. Si no, tendremos serios problemas.
CA: Pero no estás vendiendo páneles solares a los clientes.
¿Qué estás haciendo?
EM: En realidad sí se los vendemos. El cliente puede
comprar o tomar en leasing la instalación solar.
La mayoría elige el leasing.
Lo bueno de la energía solar es que
no requiere materias primas ni tiene costos operativos
solo hay que instalarla, eso es todo.
Funciona durante décadas. Probablemente incluso un siglo.
Por lo que la clave es conseguir que el costo
de la instalación incial sea bajo
y que la financiación sea baja,
porque ese interés... esos son los dos factores que componen el costo de la energía solar.
Hemos hecho grandes progresos en esa dirección,
por eso estoy convencido de que superaremos al gas natural.
CA: Lo que propones a los clientes es
que no paguen mucho inicialmente.
EM: Cero. CA: Que no paguen nada inicialmente.
Nosotros instalamos los paneles en el techo.
Y ellos pagan después. ¿Cuánto dura un leasing?
EM: Lo típico es 20 años.
Lo que proponemos, como sugieres, es muy sencillo.
No hay que poner dinero y la cuenta de electricidad baja.
Un buen trato.
CA: Todo parece bonito para el consumidor.
Sin riesgos y se paga menos que ahora.
Lo ideal sería...
Quiero decir, ¿A quién le pertenece la electricidad de los paneles a largo plazo?
¿Dónde está el beneficio para tu compañia?
EM: Bueno, básicamente,
SolarCity consigue capital
de, digamos, una compañia o un banco.
Google es uno de nuestros grandes socios aquí.
Esas compañías tienen una esperanza de retorno del capital.
Con ese capital, SolarCity compra e instala los panales en el techo
y cobra al propietario de la vivienda o del negocio
una cuota mensual de leasing que es menos que su factura eléctrica.
CA: Pero tu obtienes un beneficio comercial a largo plazo de esa energía.
Estás creando un nuevo tipo de suministro de servicio eléctrico.
EM: Exacto. Se trata de un
gran sistema de suministro.
Creo que es positivo, porque el servicio eléctrico
siempre ha sido un monopolio y la gente no ha podido elegir.
Efectivamente, por primera vez
habrá competencia ante ese monopolio.
Las empresas de energía siempre
han sido propietarias de las redes de distribución. Pero ahora todo estará en el techo.
Creo que es ventajoso para
los propietarios de viviendas y para los negocios.
CA: ¿De verdad te imaginas un futuro
en el que la mayoría de la energía de los EEUU
en una década o dos, o durante tu vida, sea solar?
EM: Estoy convencido de que la energía solar será parte del abanico energético,
y, probablemente, la preferida.
Además pronostico que esto sucederá en menos de 20 años.
Lo he apostado con alguien. CA: ¿Cómo defines ese abanico energético?
EM: Más energía solar que de otras fuentes.
CA: ¡Ah! ¿con quién lo has apostado?
EM: Con un amigo que permanecerá en el anonimato.
CA: Aquí entre nosotros. (Risa)
EM: La apuesta la hicimos hará unos dos o tres años,
por lo que, en unos 18 años, creo
que la energía solar será la fuente principal de energía.
CA: Muy bien, volvamos a otra apuesta que hiciste
contigo mismo. Una apuesta bastante disparatada.
Conseguiste algo de dinero con la venta de PayPal
y decidiste montar una empresa aeroespacial.
¿Por qué demonios hiciste algo así?
(Risas)
EM: Me hacen mucho esa pregunta, es verdad.
La gente diría: "¿Te sabes el chiste sobre el tío que
hizo una pequeña fortuna en la industria aeroespacial?"
Obviamente, el final es: "Bueno, empezó con una grande".
Lo que le digo a la gente es que estaba buscando
la forma más rápida de convertir una gran fortuna en una pequeña.
Y siempre me miran como diciendo: "¿lo dices en serio?"
CA: Extrañamente ibas en serio. ¿Qué pasó?
EM: Muy cerca. Las cosas casi que no funcionaban.
Estuvimos muy cerca de fracasar,
pero conseguimos superar ese punto en 2008.
El objetivo de SpaceX es impulsar la tecnología aeroespacial
y, en concreto, tratar de resolver un problema
que, creo, es vital
para la humanidad para poder volverse una civilización espacial
Se trata de contar con un cohete totalmente reutilizable.
CA: ¿Conquistará la humanidad el espacio en algún momento?
¿Es ese tu sueño desde pequeño?
¿Soñabas con Marte y más allá?
EM: Cuando era un niño ya construía cohetes,
pero nunca pensé que llegaría a involucrarme en ello.
En realidad era más con el enfoque de, en
qué cosas necesita el futuro
para llegar a ser apasionante y estimulante.
Realmente creo que hay una diferencia fundamental,
si miras al futuro,
entre una humanidad que conquista el espacio,
que explora las estrellas, que está en muchos planetas,
creo que es apasionante,
comparado con una en la que estamos confinados en la Tierra para siempre
hasta una posible extinción final.
CA: Has reducido el costo de construcción de
un cohete en un 75%, según cómo se calcule.
¿Cómo demonios lo has conseguido?
La NASA lleva años en esto. ¿Cómo lo has logrado?
EM: Bueno, hemos progresado mucho
en tecnología de estructuras, de motores,
de componentes electrónicos y en el lanzamiento.
Hay una lista larga de innovaciones
que hemos logrado
que serían difíciles de explicar en esta charla, pero...
CA: Además podrían copiarte, ¿no?
No has patentado nada de esto. Me parece muy interesante.
EM: No, no patentamos nada. CA: No patentas porque creés que
es más peligroso patentar que no patentar.
EM: Ya que nuestros principales competidores son los gobiernos,
la efectividad de las patentes es cuestionable.(Risas) (Aplausos)
CA: Es muy interesante.
Pero la gran innovación está por venir
y ya estás trabajando en ello. Cuéntanos un poco.
EM: Bien, la gran innovación...
CA: De hecho, podemos poner el video y nos vas comentando de qué se trata.
EM: Por supuesto. La cuestión con los cohetes
es que se pierden al desprenderse.
Todos los cohetes que se lanzan hoy en día son así.
El transbordador espacial es un intento de cohete reutilizable,
pero incluso el tanque principal del trasbordador se desechaba
y las partes reutilizables
necesitaban un grupo de 10.000 personas y nueve meses para poder ser reutilizadas en otro vuelo.
Por eso el trasbordador espacial terminó costando mil millones de dólares por vuelo.
Obviamente no es lo mejor...
CA: ¿Qué pasó ahí? ¿Vimos algo aterrizando?
EM: Así es. Lo importante es que las etapas del cohete
puedan volver, puedan regresar al lugar de lanzamiento
y estén listas para el próximo lanzamiento en cuestión de horas.
CA: Increíble, cohetes reutilizables. EM: Sí. (Aplausos)
Mucha gente no se da cuenta de que
el costo del combustible, del propulsor, es muy pequeño.
Es casi como en un jet.
El costo del propulsor es de cerca del 0,3 por ciento
del costo del cohete.
Por lo que es posible, digamos,
una reducción de casi 100 veces en los costos del vuelo espacial
si se logra reutilizar el cohete.
Por eso es tan imporante.
Todos los medios de transporte que usamos,
ya sean aviones, trenes, automóviles, bicicletas o caballos
son reutilizables excepto los cohetes.
Por lo que tenemos que resolver este problema si queremos llegar a conquistar el espacio.
CA: Me preguntabas antes que
qué popularidad tendrían los cruceros
si después tuviéramos que quemar las naves. EM: Sí, algunos cruceros parecen ser muy problemáticos.
CA: Sin duda mucho más caros.
Estamos ante una tecnología deshechadora en potencia.
Supongo que esto allana el camino hacia tu sueño
de llevar parte de la humanidad a Marte.
Te encantaría ver una colonia en Marte.
EM: Sí, exacto. SpaceX, o una combinación de
compañias y gobiernos tienen que progresar
en hacer de la vida algo multiplanetario.
En establecer bases en otros planetas,
en Marte --que es la única opción realista--
y luego ampliar esa base
hasta que seamos una especie multiplanetaria.
CA: ¿Y el avance en este "vamos a reutilizar"?
¿Cómo se está dando? El video que hemos visto era solo una simulación.
¿Cómo van las cosas?
EM: En realidad hemos avanzado mucho últimamente
con algo que llamamos el Proyecto de Prueba Saltamontes,
con el que estamos probando la parte del aterrizaje vertical del vuelo,
que es la parte final y es bastante complicada.
Hemos tenido buenos resultados en las pruebas.
CA: ¿Podemos verlo? EM: Claro.
Esto es solo para dar una idea de la escala.
Disfrazamos a un cowboy de Johnny Cash
y despues atornillamos el maniquí al cohete. (Risas)
CA: Muy bien, veamos el video entonces,
porque, si te lo planteas, es realmente increíble.
Es algo nunca visto antes. Un cohete despegando y entonces...
EM: Sí, el cohete tiene la altura de
un edificio de 12 plantas.
(Lanzamiento del cohete)
Ahora mismo está flotando a unos 40 metros
y está ajustando constantemente
el ángulo, el cabeceo, el viraje del motor principal
y equilibrándose con propulsores a gas de carbón.
CA: Es genial. (Aplausos)
Elon, ¿cómo lo has conseguido?
Estos proyectos son tan... Paypal, SolarCity,
Tesla, SpaceX, son tremendamente diferentes.
Son proyectos muy ambiciosos a gran escala.
¿Cómo demonios una sola persona
puede innovar de esta manera?
¿Cuál es tu secreto?
EM: En realidad no lo sé.
Creo que no tengo respuesta para eso.
Trabajo mucho, muchísimo.
CA: Bueno, yo tengo una teoría. EM: Bien, veamos.
CA: Mi teoría es que
eres capaz de pensar a nivel del sistema
que conjuga tecnología, negocios y diseño,
de tal manera que si TED fuese TND, tecnología, negocios y diseño,
todo en un paquete,
y lo sintetizas de una manera que muy pocos pueden,
y esto es lo más crítico, y además te sientes tan seguro
cuando todo encaja, que eres capaz de asumir riesgos enormes.
Arriesgas tu fortuna en ello, y parece que lo has hecho varias veces.
Prácticamente nadie puede hacer algo así.
Es... ¿podemos beber un poco de esa poción mágica?
¿Podemos poner un poco en nuestro sistema educativo? ¿Podemos aprender de ti?
Es realmente increíble lo que has conseguido.
EM: Bueno, gracias. Muchas gracias.
Creo que hay un ámbito perfecto para pensar.
La física. Es decir, los principios básicos.
Por regla general pienso que hay que... lo que quiero decir es,
que hay que reducir las cosas a sus bases fundamentales
y empezar a razonar desde ahí,
por oposición a trabajar por analogía.
Vamos por la vida, en su mayor parte,
razonando por analogía,
que, básicamente, implica copiar lo que hacen los demás con pequeñas variaciones.
Y hay que hacerlo así.
Si no, mentalmente no podríamos soportar ni un día.
Pero cuando quieres hacer algo nuevo
tienes que aplicar la estrategia de la física.
La física consiste en ingeniárselas para descubrir
cosas nuevas, contrarias a la intuición, como la mecánica cuántica.
Va muy en contra de la intuición.
Creo que es importante hacerlo así.
Y también prestar atención a las críticas adversas
e incluso pedirlas, especialmente a los amigos.
Esto puede parecer un simple consejo,
pero casi nadie lo hace.
y es tremendamente útil.
CA: Chicos y chicas que nos están viendo, estudien física.
Aprendan de este hombre.
Elon Musk, ojala tuviésemos todo el día... Pero muchas gracias por venir a TED.
EM: Gracias a ti. CA: Ha sido maravilloso, verdaderamente genial.
Mírenlo. (Aplausos)
Saluda al público. Ha sido fantástico.
Muchísimas gracias.